what did you do to make money like while
you were because we all I was a waitress
I had like many jobs but I feel like we
all were waiters at some point always
yeah I definitely were you good at that
waited tables you know what I was good
at I wasn't great at the actual
etiquette of waiting picking up and
dropping off and I'm gonna do all this
yeah I was good at observing if a couple
wanted to be entertained or left alone
oh and and I was good at noticing
reading the room reading a room and if
we were late and getting the food out I
would just bring them some shrimp
cocktail or something like I'm so sorry
here's something free you know and they
were yeah very grateful for that so I I
kind of made it you're a gray waiter
that was yeah I want that waiter yeah
yeah I feel like that's a great waiter
no I didn't want to be exactly while I'm
waiting on my food yeah and I also I
also loaded trucks in downtown Los
Angeles Andy Garcia was one of the other
guys down there doing it doing the same
thing yes ma'am that's so hard work yeah
yeah then I was a videotape interviewer
for a dating service called Great
Expectations
[Laughter]
the dating service is Great Expectations
I feel like you're setting yourself up
for failure
those expectations better be great did
you reach them I know I was like wait so
wait so here's the thing we got wind of
this and this is my favorite thing so
you mean this service roll the tape
you made a smart decision by joining
Great Expectations now keep Your
positive momentum going make sure to
keep your appointment for your photo and
video and set aside some time to read
the great success workbook in your new
member kit
here's the thing you were revolutionary
because here's the thing now all these
apps do exactly this that's right in an
app world we were ahead of the game
that's right you would you would slide
right or slide left but you didn't do
anything in those days
um no it was the precursor to all those
uh you know Match.com and things like
that I know it actually worked really
well did I was gonna ask did couples
really come together on that and got
married and yes okay
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]